ciao a tutti ragazzi e poi venuto questo
video sono fa vj esercizio su come si
chiama up in the town red nel caso ve lo
stesse chiedendo l'alzheimer procede
bene e mi sa che mi sono beccato pure
l'influenza quindi c'è una voce di merda
accordo ragazzi abbiamo fatto una mappa
dipende da un red ce ne sono altre
volevo fare la prigione ma eccola bello
questo ragazzi e il comodissimo accesso
lavandino comunemente utilizzato per
cagare e lavarsi le mani a mo di
contorsionista e ti vengo a picchiare
perché stai picchiando uno dei miei
amici però lo faccio dopo perché prima
voglio guardarmi attivi in giro senti mi
scusami caro ed erano nove continua
tranquillo non ti voglio da fare per
farveli che mi si è girato ma ha capito
che non gli do fastidio giorno che
belliche sono figurali tocco nomi di
dominio picchiano poi va bene quello ba
cosa fa questo lo sta facendo
[Musica]
non so quale dei due sia migliore a
ballare questi che giocano a basket
che cosa ti guardi posso provare a fare
un canestro prove
no no no non c'è il 3 credimi che non
volerne col quale nudo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
perché c'è una nuda due cose numero 1
come ho fatto a scassare il cervello di
un tizio con una palla da basket
non pensavo che il basket fosse così
violento voglio capire perché c'è uno
perché hanno smaterializzano il taser
vuoi vedere il cd di gigi d'alessio come
ti uccide per un attimo campi chiudi
chiudi più di più di più richiudi chiudi
veloce
no ma aiuta se non ho mai fatto la
partita più bella di questa la mela fa
meno male della palma della lebron james
lebron james trick shot personale brotto
disperate ma quello e succo di mela cioè
non può essere altrimenti come può
uscire il sangue
allora questo è un mandarino ok
mandarino è un mandarino
come fai a morire che guarda che strage
il mondo
fermi e guardami guardami zio guardami
mamma è la madonna quale gestore
valestra eh vabbè stanno incazza cos'è
perché c'è un braccio nel muro io si
esce un sorvegliato speciale fermi un
attimo fermi tutti devo andare a vedere
cosa sta succedendo
e c'è un braccio di ancora non capisco
zio e c'è un tizio posso vedere questo
qua dentro
chi sei e cosa vuoi da me non ho fatto
niente e lui che ci al machete no no non
mi rompere la vita e vabbè solo morto
legame mi faccio uccidere tanto stavolta
la stessa la vostra cosa significhi
elettrici di una bistecca vabbè ragazza
disse che la facciano meno pixellosa in
minecraft e volevo dirvelo bello perché
vuole morto con una bistecca giusto per
fare canestro no perché non sono
impedito a basket ma che come fa
rimbalzare una palla quadrata perché
tutto quadrati i suoi novant'anni
sto solo chiarendo delle cose di fisica
tranquilli non ti in casa ma poi nulla
contro la mia frutta guarda che armeria
che ciò qua berserk le diceva posso fare
che non ho capito cosa può fare berserk
però non mi ricordo più c'è ha già i
pugni ai pugni fortissimi tipo chi
minchia affetto beh non è forti pensavo
peggio
poi col fatto che a rallentare che ci
metto un ora in più cosa guarda questo
non c'è la bocca adesso non c'è più la
faccia proprio la nato discorso aveva
quanto è grosso
ma chi è perché c'è 11 su un gigante in
caserma assieme sheen jackie nostra
nicchia però è immune al tese a figlio
inciampato ci siamo
fermi voglio solo capire dove il tizio
se io non so se è la prima regola di
quando ti fai la doccia nelle carceri e
non farti cadere lo saponetta quando c'è
un tizio nero che ti aspetta
fa anche rima ce lo fa rimane a posto no
no via via via via io ho questo tavolo e
voi non aver mai chiesto tizio
comunque io ho un tavolo e voi siete
delle merde vi posso stare dietro il
tavolo finché non sacchetta volo va a
[ __ ] c'è la narco letto
e stato bello ciao hiv a ce l'ho fatta
sono fuggito non so come sono fuggito
ragazzi il tipo e ultimi smythe ci siamo
ragazzi ci siamo sbaglio nara baby è
morto è morto né può non può nulla
trovar da lì va a tallinn guardale
smaterializza tissima invece no ora che
non muore
non ci credo mai non sta non sta
seriamente morendo è veramente ragazzi
non sta morendo e non mi spiego il
perché non sta e morto è morto è morto
anche casinò fatto un disastro
non lo sappiamo il naso no non ci credo
io provo la sedia non mi rincorreva così
cose diaman col prof quando doveva fare
verifiche
questo è svenuto questi giorni fa
ginnaste vite parallele
quei media che sull'etna o ragazza non
usavo quello era morto e non questo non
c'è questo c'è solo la manica gli è
rimasta solo la manica il braccio non
c'è la mano neanche programma nicácio 98
76 e ci siamo ragazzi lo dovrei aver
vinto 12 da è morto ragazzi ne mancano
due sono lì che si fanno i cazzi loro
perché devo ucciderli ecco adesso non si
stanno più facendo i casi lo bello che
si è il lancio sta cosa
effetto 1 ragazzi devo finirlo con la
mia arma segreta eccola muori stronzo
ebbene sì ciao
e stato bello parigi non lo può battere
ne sono di qua posso uscire grassi
emersi beaucoup succede qua perfetto
avete presente come si va dalle prigioni
cioè quelli che scavano con le cose non
serve un cazzo legale in realtà dalle
prigioni si evade facendo fuori tutti
comunque sia ragazzi spero che vi sia
piaciuto è stato è e sarà in realtà era
era questa la mappa principale di paint
the town legge o una ragazza comunque
che non ho fatto che sarebbe questa qui
è via in discoteca santo dio e il
prossimo episodio scopriamo se capri
ponte sarà presente perché non è
possibile che spero che viene vi sia
piaciuto ragazzi e cosa è subito
piaciuta l'argomento è un mi piace anche
a pagina di facebook con il video tra
tende schizzi hansen e sera il city
scriveteci vediamo questo video
porca eva beh ragazzi